direction versailles à présent où l'un
des plus grand musée de l'histoire de
france vient de rouvrir certaines de ces
salles le site le château et ses
galeries où désormais plus de mille cinq
cents oeuvres sont présentées au public
sur 5000 mètres carrés des oeuvres qui
raconte l'histoire de france dont
l'accession au pouvoir de louis philippe
qui fut à l'origine de ce musée visite
guidée avec karine shana et marque doux
10 juin 10 837
derrière ses fenêtres du château de
versailles c'est l'effervescence
devant des centaines d'invités le roi
louis-philippe inaugure son musée
d'histoire dédié à toutes les gloires de
france un musée enrichi de pluies dans
certaines salles totalement ou
partiellement fermés faute d'agents de
surveillance hors ouvre aujourd'hui et
comme un immense livre ouvert dans la
galerie des batailles ce sont les plus
grandes victoires de l'histoire de
france qui sont illustrés entre tolbiac
et wagram des oeuvres signées horace
vernet ou encore à delacroix et
mortalité en saint louis en pleine
bataille de taillebourg
autre porte d'entrée sur l'histoire dans
cette salle le décor est résolument
néogothique les oeuvres elles racontent
les croisades mais pour louis philippe
la vocation de ce musée est aussi
politique
il avait besoin de rallier à sa
politique à sa personne tous les partis
politiques de l'époque des légitimistes
au bonapartiste aux républicains et
jusqu'aux orléaniste qui était son
propre parti
ouais
les orléanistes la révolution de 1830
qui l'a porté au pouvoir oui philippe va
encore est consacré toute une salle et
avec celle illustrant le règne de louis
xiv c'est près d'un tiers de ce musée
qui dévoile aujourd'hui ses trésors
musée qui à l'époque sauva le château de
la ruine